our draft today the most dangerous
offense is currently in the national
football league Peter you know how this
goes now no more coin tosses trivia
question and I've got a question for you
and if you get it right you get the
first pick here it is
dak Prescott currently leads the NFL in
passing yards with 3221
who was the last Cowboys quarterback to
lead the NFL in passing yards in a
single season Tony Romo I'm waiting for
the sound do we have the sound the sound
must be down now in this look it's not
Tony Romo it was a kind of a trick
question I felt bad about it no Cowboys
quarterback has ever led the league in
passing yards you know what asked me
questions like that all the time
ya know Cowboys quarterback has ever
done it so I'll go ahead and take the
first pick and you know and we're going
to continue a conversation that we had
on the TV side only because I'm taking
the Baltimore Ravens as the most
dangerous offense right now in football
because of Lamar Jackson and what we
were discussing if you were only
listening on radio and are only
listening on radio the comment from Mike
Lombardi on his podcast that Marty
morning wag the former offensive
coordinator of the team legitimately and
actually said to other coaches last year
when are we moving Lamar Jackson to wide
receiver and the Ravens issued a
statement yesterday from morning wake
who doesn't work for the team anymore
denying and refuting that and Peter you
had a point you wanted to make about
this issue of why the Ravens would feel
compelled to issue a statement regarding
something that allegedly said by
somebody who doesn't work for them
anymore well Mike you saw what happened
when Bill Polian
you know had to basically say hey listen
I was wrong when I said Lamar Jackson
should have been moved to wide receiver
imagine if somebody inside your building
and the guy who's basically responsible
for Lamar Jackson has to make a
statement like that you know to refute
what what he felt was absolutely wrong
and I heard from somebody inside the
Ravens yesterday that taken to the bank
Marty morning wake absolutely never said
that
and the reason that that that Lamar
Jackson was drafted essentially was to
create some competition at a quarterback
position that had gone stale not only
did he create the competition he won the
competition and now he's the hottest
player in the NFL and Mike you're right
the Baltimore Ravens are the best
defense offense in football yeah and
look it all hinges on Lamar Jackson
staying healthy and as time goes by
fewer and fewer opportunities for him to
get injured in the final stretch of the
season and I don't want to jinx him but
remember what happened to Robert Griffin
the third seven years ago against the
Ravens in December that was when he had
that initial knee injury then I think
was a torn ACL at the time no one's ever
admitted that but I think he tried to
play with a torn ACL in the playoffs and
it obviously didn't work but that's the
real wild card can Lamar Jackson stay
health and if he can't can rg3 who's now
the backup to Jackson come in and get it
done all right Peter you're a
first-round pick most dangerous offense
right now in the NFL
I'd say the Dallas Cowboys he even
though they're a consistent they're an
inconsistently dangerous offense to me
down the stretch they've got the two
things you have to have a strong running
game and the ability to strafe you deep
down the field so the question is can it
remain as consistent as it's been the
last couple of weeks I believe it can
give me Dallas number one yeah and
here's the thing about the Cowboys
offense and we saw them come back from a
14 nothing deficit a week and a half ago
against the Vikings so they are capable
of playing from behind it
Dallas is kind of like Minnesota which
is gonna be my next pick in that if you
take away the running game the passing
game can't always be relied upon but you
know what this year dak Prescott is
proving that it can be relied upon when
the running game isn't there because the
Seco Elliott hasn't been the same guy
this year that he's been in past years
and here we are with dak Prescott on
pace for 50-100 passing yards so I agree
with you kind of on the Cowboys I have
the same concern about them that I have
for the Vikings when you can't run the
ball but again I'm picking the Vikings
next because of the fact that you
working and they are able to run the
ball in Minnesota more often than not
when they do run up against the wall
lately Kirk Cousins been able to get it
done his passing numbers are off the
charts so give me the Vikings in round 2
Mike I'll take the Green Bay Packers
basically the Packers are heading into
you know the end of the season the the
the last few weeks and I believe they're
very much in a in Aaron Rodgers we trust
phase they've gone through different
phases this year where they've had to
rely more on the running game because
they haven't been healthy at receiver
but I think now heading into this really
tough part of the schedule give me the
quarterback who is really starting to
become one with his head coach and is
really starting to show more than any
time this year that he trusts this
offense and he trusts some of these new
weapons that he's had to get used to it
is amazing to see the growth of the
Packers offense they were so sluggish
early in the season when the defense was
playing well enough to allow them to win
games and I said at the time those winds
that they're picking up in September
money in the bank and look at where they
are now they're ahead of the Vikings by
a half game they're eight into the
Vikings are eight and three but they'd
be in second place in the division if
they hadn't stolen those wins early
before they got the lawnmower running
that is the Green Bay Packers offense
and I agree with you they're getting it
done they got it done for four straight
weeks without Davante Adams and I think
they're gonna keep getting it done their
toughest test yet though coming up
Sunday night on NBC I didn't do that to
deliberately plug Sunday Night Football
every week we have a great game but an
extra great game this Sunday night when
the Packers take on the 49ers all right
the next one for me and I'm thinking
49ers but there's one on the board we've
kind of forgotten about how can we
forget about the Kansas City Chiefs with
Patrick mahomes and Tyriq Hill and
Travis Kelce and Sammy Watkins I wish
they had a little more ability at
running back and LeSean McCoy you know
he's good enough but that that team with
mahomes the reigning MVP still plays and
can play like he played last year with
Kelsey and Hill and Watkins and McCoy
Hardman who is kind of like the next
Tyree kill in Kansas City I think that
offense incredibly dangerous and I'm
still astounded that they've lost as
many games as they have this season I
thought you were going to say hey wait a
minute we forgot about the New Orleans
Saints because to me right now when I
look at the Saints I see a quarterback
healthier by the week a wide receiver
who's unstoppable is gonna catch 150
balls or maybe 1500 balls I don't know
he's utterly preposterous every week
Michael Thomas but Mike the reason that
I'm gonna put them here in my third spot
is because right now I'm really trusting
their running game more than I have at
any point this year because I think that
latavius Murray gives them an option you
know just opposite Alvin Kamara
and to me you've got to be able to have
two running backs you trust down the
stretch of any season and right now if
I'm Sean Payton and I'm calling plays
I'm very very comfortable calling
latavius Murray number right now and you
mentioned Michael Thomas I'm glad you
did because earlier in the show we
talked a little bit about MVP and I said
that to be a non quarterback and win the
thing you've got to do something
historic if if Michael Thomas sets the
single-season reception record Marvin
Harrison currently holds it with 143 and
the Saints emerged with the number one
seed in the NFC it's gonna be not all
that difficult to make a case for
Michael Thomas no receivers ever won it
because usually if a receiver has a
great season the guy throwing the
football did too and he gets the votes
well this year you got Drew Brees who
missed five games Thomas would get the
MVP votes Peter so Michael Thomas he
wasn't on the recent odds that were put
out by Cesar sportsbook but he should be
because I think he's in the conversation
and will be if he continues to rack up
these receptions and if the Saints end
up being the number one seat the one
reason the biggest reason why you can
put them in the discussion and should
put them in the disco
is very very simple the New Orleans
Saints went five and Oh without Drew
Brees and a very big part of that was
they sputtered a little bit at first but
then after they finished the sputtering
and teddy bridgewater started to feel
comfortable you saw who his number-one
weapon was when he was trying to put up
big points and that was obviously
Michael Thomas
all right let's recap the picks from
today we left out the 49ers sorry 49ers
you've got a great offense but I've got
concerns about Jimmy Garoppolo that's
why I didn't put the 49ers in my top
three Ravens Vikings and Chiefs are mine
Peter King has the Cowboys the Packers
and the Saints
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports